verser dans la vasque dans laquelle je
puiserai pour vous baigner et bénir les
nôtres cet établissement bénédiction à
elancourt de la toute nouvelle école
privée sainte-thérèse après presque un
an de travaux elle peut désormais
accueillir douze professeurs et huit
classes de 206 élèves dont 85 élan
courtois bénir des locaux et surtout des
personnes qui vont y travailler
c'est cet insigne de qui a une relation
entre le créateur entre dieu et nous
dans les deux sens
coût de cette nouvelle école 3 millions
d'euros le financement de l'enseignement
catholique est assurée par les diocèses
et les familles seuls les coûts de
fonctionnement sont en partie financés
par les municipalités qui doivent verser
une somme correspondant au coût d'un
élève dans l'enseignement public
construire une école comme celle ci pour
nous c'est une certaine gageur
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
construire autant d'établissements qu'il
faudrait ou que les familles nous
réclament notamment et en particulier il
faut le dire sur le département
nous avons des projets à l'heure
actuelle mais qui sont davantage des
projets de rénovation d'établissements
plutôt que de nouvelles constructions en
tant que tel pour les enfants ce qui
était difficile qu'il y avait la même
cour pour les maternelles et les
primaires alors que la la cour et le
bâtiment maternelle est dissociée du
primaire l'école se trouvait auparavant
dans un centre aéré de la commune
quant au collège sainte thérèse qui
compte lui 362 élèves
il reste situé au mesnil saint denis